freunde der sonne heute ein kleines
extra video
ich werde immer wieder gefragt warum ich
das hier alles mache und ich möchte
heute mal klarstellen dass ich nicht die
einzige wissenschaftlerin bin die fremde
menschen mit wissenschaft forscht und
ich finde es sehr wichtig denn wir
werden tagtäglich mit soviel bullshit
folge quatscht dass wir wissenschaftler
da ein gegengewicht einbringen möchten
heute möchte ich euch ein paar zeilen
slammer vorstellen
das heißt victoria bin
lebensmittelchemikerin und haben nicht
mit fettreicher schokolade beschäftigt
hey ich bin musiker und suche nach dem
kleinsten bausteine unseres universums
ich heiße an die neuropsychologie und
erforsche implizite gedächtnisleistung
ich heiße martin ich bin im spiel und
ich erforsche den früheren
schweißprozess ich heiße wicke ich bin
neurowissenschaftlerin und ich erforsche
die menschliche raum wahrnehmen mein
name ist simon ich bin volkswirt und ich
forschte mögliche sachen gibt's die sind
dort zu suchen mein arbeitsfeld ich bin
medizinphysiker und ich forsche daran
wie man zum moore besser bekämpfen seien
slammer sind wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die sich auf bühnen
stellen um ihre forschung einem publikum
zu präsentieren dass im zweifelsfall
wieder ahnung von wissenschaft hat noch
nüchtern ist sprich die slammer müssen
das so kurz verständlich und
unterhaltsam wie möglich machen und die
leute lieben es so viel zur wissenschaft
ist nicht unterhaltsam
diese wundervolle menschen die sich sein
slammern verstehe ich als meine kollegen
in der wissenschaftskommunikation und
ich habe sie gebeten mir fünf fragen zu
beantworten und bitte schreibe deine
forschung in 10 sekunden
ich weiß so recht zusammen dass man sie
beheben formen kann
und das ist nicht okay wenn ich jemanden
in die wüste schickte dann ist das nicht
unhöflich sondern forschung das ist
unsere universum den teil kennen wir
schon ganz gut und hier kommen haben wir
überhaupt noch keine ahnung was es sein
könnte
und genau danach suche im grunde geht es
darum was sich menschen die alles
vergessen merken können ich habe
erforscht warum schokolade manchmal so
scheiße aussieht und diesen ekligen
überzuckert treffe ein bewegliches ziel
dass du nicht
mit einer waffe von der du keine ahnung
hast wo sie hin schließen laser tag für
blinde menschen reagieren auf anreize
anreize sind meistens nicht perfekt
gesetzt und vor allem im
gesundheitssektor kann man da noch ganz
viel ändern damit alle gesund und alle
glücklich
was ist das beste an deiner forschung
dass man die reste essen kann beste an
meiner forschung ist dass ich vielleicht
selber mal davon profitieren ich dachte
die kaputt machen und warum zahlt am
ende bleibt eigentlich nur schon und ich
finde ich die worte mit denen ich die
leute die welt zu sehen lassen kann wie
ich das bild datenanalyse das heißt wenn
ich die daten von einem laptop kann ich
das auch in spanien zum beispiel
das beste an meiner forschung ist dass
es überall sehr guten kaffee gibt die
menschen am cern aber ich nämlich tag
und nacht auf der suche nach neuen
baustein unseres universums
das ist ungefähr so wie bei einem tatort
ein zu kommen wo überall blutspritzer
sind und dann muss man herausfinden was
passiert ist denn diese neuen teilchen
zerfallen sofort und wir sehen nur ihre
bruchstücke und müssen dann
rekonstruieren was noch in dieser welt
zu entdecken ist
ich darf mit auf vielen großen maschinen
spielen das alles mit euren steuergeld
wie zum beispiel unter diesem hügel der
komplett gefüllt ist mit einer riesigen
strahlen kann ohne einen kleinen schrank
an ohne eine mercedes ganz ganz viele
verschiedene 3d drucker welches ist die
coolste wissenschaft und warum
das ist ganz einfach die
kunstwissenschaft das ist für mich die
chemie denn dinge die ich im studium
gelernt habe mit denen kann ich mir
eigentlich die ganze welt erklärt die
coolste naturwissenschaft für mich ist
die physik weil sie unser gesamtes
universum beschreiben kann von den
größten galaxienhaufen bis zum kleinsten
subatomaren teilchen die coolste
wissenschaft ist die paläontologie auf
jeden fall paläontologe dinosaurier
nicht nur riesig groß waren sondern auch
150 millionen jahre lang die erde
beherrschten studium reist man die ganze
zeit um einbuddeln die usa etwas gibt es
ein cooleres die coolste wissenschaft
ist die neurowissenschaft weil sie sich
mit dem gehirn beschäftigt ein organ
dass wir nicht ganz verstehen mit dem
wir aber trotzdem die welt verstehen wie
cool ist das denn
ingenieurswissenschaften weil wir können
euch alles habt ihr jemals ein produkt
gesehen und nicht irgendwer seine finger
im spiel hatte auf jeden fall
kunstgeschichte
die können wir mit wenn er so ein bild
irgendwie 600 jahre alt ist rausfinden
was die menschen sich dabei gedacht
haben vor 600 jahren das ist sehr
beeindrucken oder medizin die können
menschenleben retten und krankheiten
heilen das auch nicht schlecht dass ich
konnte mir macht spaß ist auch nicht
unwichtig er ich würde sagen
kunstgeschichte auf keinen fall jung du
kein wissenschaftler oder keinen
wissenschaftlerin wärst was wärst du da
auf jeden fall pilot weil die künftig
kein anderer kinder
vielleicht heißt es auf gut deutsch ob
sie auf die server profitieren also hat
er da mache ich ihn nicht einfach schöne
strecke sehr gut ich bin kein
wissenschaftler mehr
aber wenn ich kein wissenschaftler wäre
das werde ich dann das was ich bin im
bereich wissenschaftsjournalismus
unterwegs wenn ich keine wissenschaftler
geworden wäre wäre ich wahrscheinlich
professioneller tunnels spieler geworden
und lässt warum solltet ihr da draußen
die zuschauer mal zu einem science slam
gehen weil die wissenschaft die größte
menschen nicht errungenschaft ist seit
der entwicklung des portals ganz einfach
er das spielerische art und weise was
gerade so in der wissenschaft abgeht und
es gibt bier müssen abend an dem man
trinken kann und was werden
erst dann gibt es natürlich gutes bier
schauen wir uns hier verschiedene
freizeitaktivitäten gegliedert nach
wissenszuwachs und unterhaltungsfaktor
geht es lustig zu kommen die ist lustig
aber wir werden in den seltensten fällen
etwas dazu ganz anders der mathematik
für die meisten menschen ist mathematik
nicht sehr witzig aber man kann verdammt
viel barilla hier ist meistens sehr
witzig geht aber häufig mit verlust von
westen her wieder treten wolle es gibt
bier kann sowohl gute unterhaltung und
kann dazu noch was lernen
du kommst auch mit wissenschaftler in
kontakt und kannst du nach deinem ihr
hingehen und
fragen stellen und sagen mensch wissen
das genau ist gute stimmung hast spaß
und du bekommst eine ganz schön große
portion horizont erweiterung zum
mitnehmen
ich meine klar und öffentliche gebäude
da kannst du auch so reingehen aber ist
zum teil der mystery wenn du einfach bei
seinem professor blogs und sagt hallo
ich habe meine frage also das ist
eigentlich besser zum science slam zu
gehen lohnt sich auf alle fälle wären ja
voll auch alles nicht abgestempelt und
ich hoffe dass das science slam gilt bis
zu ändern
für alle die spaß an wissenschaft haben
dazu zähle ich jetzt mal alle schön
schlau abonnenten gehen kann ich seines
lebens noten viel weil sie dass wir
heute am samstag den oktober schaut dann
finden heute abend die süddeutschen
meisterschaften im science slam statt
und die leute die ihr gerade gesehen
habt sind die teilnehmer das ist
allerdings völlig ohne zu wissen für
euch weil die süddeutsche meisterschaft
im science slams schon komplett
ausverkauft wird
aber schaut mal in die video
beschreibung da habe ich euch ein paar
sachen verlinkt den science slams finden
regelmäßig und überall in deutschland
statt also freunde der sonne ich wünsche
euch was wir sehen uns nächste woche bis
dahin bleibt sich die kurse wissenschaft
ist
[Musik]
wir werden ja vorlauf 1 märz abgestimmt
ich hoffe dass das einst lernt dabei
hilft dieses geschieht zu bekräftigen
als liebert